so welcome everyone hello it's my
pleasure to um invite you here all today
um and thank you for joining us my name
is Melissa Brennan and I work in the
institutional advancement um an alumni
relations office at brandise University
and we're very excited to have with us
today uh our guest speaker Simon cnnic
class of 95 uh the title of the talk is
why the best companies are built around
optimism and I don't know about you but
I feel the world can always use more
optimism and more Optimist um I'd like
to let you know that today's webinar is
sponsored by the brandise international
business school hayatt career center and
the brandise Alumni Association and
before we begin I was delighted to
introduce uh Philipe Wells who is a
professor of the practice of
entrepreneurial Finance in the brandise
international business school and he is
the director of the aspir center for
Global entrepreneurship at brandise uh
Professor Wells teach teaches courses on
entrepreneurship private equity and
introduction to business and I would
also note that he is a seasoned
entrepreneur and the health and wellness
industry when with that said I'm GNA
turn it over to Professor WS thank you
great thank you so much Melissa so as
Melissa said we're very fortunate today
to have Simon cynic join us uh Simon's
one of the most highly viewed Ted Talk
speakers as well as the author of
multiple bestselling books including
start with why the infinite game and
Leaders Eat Last he received a ba in
cultural anthropology from brandise and
went on to study law before he left law
school to go into
advertising Simon's fascinated by the
people and organizations that make the
greatest and longest lasting impact over
the years he's discovered some
remarkable patterns about how they act
think and communicate and also the
environments in which people operate at
their natural best Simon shares
inspiration on a daily basis through his
best-selling books as well as his
podcast a bit of optimism in addition
Simon's the founder of the optimism
company a Leadership Learning and
Development company and he publishes
other inspiring thinkers and doers
through his partnership with penguin
Random House called optimism press so uh
with that Simon I'd love to get
started good to see you good to see you
yes um well why don't I just I'll just
jump right into the questions and I do
actually want to encourage the room we
went over this with Simon just before we
got on the call and Simon very much he's
he's here to answer your questions he's
he's not here to uh you know to
summarize and talk about all his books
he's here to to share his insights in
who he is and how he thinks so whenever
you have questions just feel free to add
them to the queue um so with that Simon
the the class here that's sort of at the
core of our talk and our invitation
today for this talk is actually an
entrepreneurship class and our tool from
for analyzing entrepreneurship is
something called The Lean Startup
framework it deals with things like
minimal viable products hypothesis
testing and so on now the question that
occurred to me as I was thinking about
this talk and having you here is what
would be the outline or the parameters
behind the optimistic
startup it's a great question um
so first of all let's define a few terms
you know I think there's a big
difference between being an entrepreneur
and being a small business owner uh
small business owners own small
businesses but entrepreneurs are problem
solvers and you find entrepreneurs in
government you find entrepreneurs in
large corporations um they're not simply
people who start businesses Richard
Branson's an entrepreneur but he doesn't
own a small business anymore um um and
so I think we have to remember that you
know that that an entrepreneur is a
problem solver um and they don't go
around solving random problems that's
that's weird um you know the best
entrepreneurs usually have some sort of
vision of the world that does not yet
exist in other words they're idealists
in some way shape or form and you know
in their early years when they're young
it's probably some gut feeling and later
on hopefully they can articulate what
that vision is in terms that can Inspire
more people around them and the ones
that achieve scale definitely are
capable of doing
that um and so when I think about the
optimistic leader I mean number one they
have to have vision and vision is not
like to build the best most reliable you
know highest quality product that's not
Vision vision is I imagine a world in
which you know uh Steve Jobs and Steve
wnc had Vision they imagined a world in
which an individual could compete
against a corporation There Was You Know
fundamentally sort of like you know
revolutionary Spirit and the personal
computer was the mechanism by which they
used to do that if the company was
founded 30 years later it would be a it
would be a it would be a tech company
not a not a hardware company um you know
it's just nature of the times that was
founded and the tools that were
available um my own Vision I imagine a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
end the day fulfilled by the work that
they do entrepreneurship comes in
looking for the path that helps me move
closer towards that Vision so I for me
an an optimistic entrepreneur is someone
with vision and looking looking for the
best tools to advance that
Vision great sounds sounds good um so
the next question wanted to get into is
you you have this famous talk about the
workplace and Millennials and I know you
get asked as well about gen Z in the
workplace well we have a lot of gen zers
on this call and actually what I wanted
to ask you is how to think how they
should think about preparing for the
workplace so you know this is a class
we're preparing them to think about
entrepreneurship and um how to you know
go out and innovate how should they
prepare more broadly for the workplace
given what you've set out as sort of
some of the defining characteristics of
the of the workplace
today so there was a great disservice
that was done to capitalism uh over the
course of the 80s 90s and 2000s um and
that disservice was perpetuated by
leaders like Jack Welch um and basically
what they did is they made business in
America more about value to a
shareholder an external
constituent over a customer or an
employee and remember good oldfashioned
Adam Smith capitalism the kind of
capitalism that made America great the
kind of capitalism that Thomas Jefferson
studied Thomas Jefferson owned all the
volumes of Wealth of
Nations um that form of capitalism
believed in competition as a means of
producing a higher quality product we
now live in a world where that's not
really true um that when a company for
example announces Mass layoffs to meet
some arbitrary Financial projection um
we see a stock price goes up go up this
is a big problem um and many of the
inherent deals that were made between a
company and this employer or a company
and the customer used to be you know
that we will work tirelessly in our
competitive Spirit to make a better
product from you and we will work
tirelessly to look after our people so
that our people give back years of
loyalty and unfortunately this Young
Generation has grown up in a world where
Mass layoffs are so normalized where
they've watched their parents or their
friends parents be laid off through no
fault of their own it was not a
meritocracy just because the company
missed like I said an AR arbitrary
projection it's profitable just not as
profitable as we expected so you get to
lose your job as a result so I can go
back and prove to to somebody that I
balance the books even though I'm doing
long-term damage to the culture of the
company and that deal was broken that
deal was broken that I'm going to take
care of you and you're going to take
care of me and so it's very funny to me
that companies lament that this young
generation seems to offer no loyalty to
the
company um when they offer they have
offered none for
decades um and in the process of of
business becoming much more short-term
much more transactional and the human
element um falling the Wayside we've
also seen a decline in a very very very
specific skill set called human skills
right I I hate the term soft skills hard
term hard skills and soft skills hard
and soft are opposite that means they
work in opposition to each other right
hard skills the skills you need to do
your job and human skills the skills you
need to be a better human being and both
of those are important to be a great
entrepreneur and a and a and a great and
and a great business person and though
we teach hard skills and we teach how to
read a balance sheet and what a p&l is
and we teach all of these wonderful
things unfortunately we started to treat
people like something on a p&l and what
we have to do better is teaching human
skills human skills include things like
listening like uh empathy like how to
give and receive feedback like how to
have a difficult conversation these are
vital skills in a modern day that we
don't teach which means our Business
Leaders do not have those skills and if
you want to build culture if you want to
build trust you need these skills if you
want to manage difficult times you need
to have these
skills take for example what happened
after the murder of George Floyd and I
saw this pervasive the number of leaders
after the murder of George Floyd do
nothing not because they're bad people
it's because they were too afraid to
have a conversation about race with
their team fearing that they would say
the wrong thing and accidentally inflame
a situation or trigger somebody so they
chose
nothing and I don't fault them for it
what they're missing is a necessary
skill set how to have a difficult
conversation hey team we need to have a
difficult conversation um I'm afraid to
have this conversation I fear I'm gonna
say the wrong thing or accidentally
trigger somebody and I and I and I'm and
I need your help because I I'm going to
Fumble this but it's more important that
we have this conversation than not
simply because I'm afraid that's how you
start a difficult conversation that is a
teachable learnable practice practicable
practice skill set so one thing that I
would like to see more of in our
University system to prepare young
people as they enter the workforce where
they choose an entrepreneurial path or
not is to be better equipped with these
skills because their companies as of now
are doing a poor job of equipping them
and and if they are going to be the
Future Leaders um I want them to bring
these skills to business to repair the
capitalism and repair the Damage Done by
folks like Jack
Welch yeah thank you so we're starting
to get a bunch of questions here in the
Q&A um thank you audience for putting
the questions in encourage you to put in
more so this is kind
of I think you've already got into this
I mean the question basically is how
would you recommend we begin teaching
these soft skills so human skills
exactly exactly two points one they're
not sof skills not point is you said
they're teachable maybe just talk a
little bit more about what that would
entail so they are not soft there is
nothing soft about having a very
uncomfortable conversation with somebody
um um so the question is where do you
start teaching well there's plenty of
curriculum available but it's usually in
different departments go to the social
work department you know go go go go go
look at parenting education there's tons
of curriculum available but we don't put
it in in the business school uh and we
need to um a a course on active
listening for example you know we are
terrible listeners uh we're good at
screaming and yelling and we're terrible
at listening um the mere fact that
there's even you know it's even a thing
it's even a meme about how to get
through Thanksgiving because of your
uncle who has you know opposite
political views at you and the best
advice we get is don't bring up politics
at the Thanksgiving table that's
nonsense how about learn to have an
uncomfortable conversation and learn to
listen someone's point of view when you
vehemently disagree with them and
sitting down trying to convince them is
not listening trying to understand and
have empathy is listening and when two
people with opposing points of view can
find Common Ground that's where growth
happens and I'll give you a real life
example from you know in my life I have
a friend um she is from rural Tennessee
and uh we discovered over the course of
our friendship just how Divergent our
political views and views on how the
world works are to the you know some of
she buys into some you know conspiracy
theories um and she and I went for a
walk once uh and we were talking about
something and I definitely thought and I
may have even said how can you be so
stupid and she stopped in her tracks and
said you just called your friends stupid
and I realized what have I done I'm
literally closing off any opportunity
for constructive conversation here
because I judged and accused even if I
think whatever Theory she's buying into
is not grounded in fact I I attacked
her and so I had to learn to take a step
back and embrace empathy and instead of
trying to convince her that she was
wrong or point out the facts that
dispute her beliefs i instead went on a
journey of learning to listen and
understand how she came to believe in
the things she believes and during Co we
had many
conversations that were diametrically
opposed and instead of attacking each
other or trying to convince each other
um we got really good at saying tell me
more about that you know where does that
come from and almost always I could find
a fact or I could find a detail that
says you're absolutely right there that
is absolutely true and the minute we
could find Common Ground all of a sudden
we could build up from there and she
became much more open to some of the
points of view I had as soon as I could
affirm um uh some element in what she
had or find something I agreed with and
that skill of active listening is
incredibly difficult but immensely
valuable in finding coming ground um
especially with people with political
different political points of view but
the point is is you're going to have
disagreements with people about what to
what decision to make for the company
you know um you're going to have you're
going to have decisions about what to do
with a uh an underperforming employee
you know what what do we do you know
somebody who's resistant to coaching how
do how do we react you know like
difficulty is the nature of the game
there's nothing smooth about business um
it is an incredibly complicated uh uh uh
game that is it's a game of people right
it's all people customers are people
investors are people employees are
people like everybody's people and
people are messy and they're filled with
ego and insecurity and ambition and fear
and all the rest of it congratulations
there's your
company um and you know the best leaders
are the ones who who aren't necessarily
the best at reading the p&l the best
leaders are the ones who have who learn
and commit themselves to learning all
the skills necessary to navigate those
complications and in so doing building
trust from their team that gives them
permission to even make
mistakes yeah great I mean I think so my
next question feeds right into what you
were talking about um the question from
roey is how can you remain optimistic as
a leader on a team when others are not
bought into the team's end goal and I
think we kind of set that question up
but is there anything else to add sort
of like how does the leader remain
optimistic it's complicated it's messy
as you were saying okay so there's
there's a answers there if you're the
person doing the hiring then you have a
responsibility to put out what your
vision is and if you're just hiring a
skill set and you're ignoring whether
that potential that future employee that
candidate even believes in what you
believe then if you hired somebody who
shouldn't be on the team then you bear
some responsibility you can't just
scream and yell at them and call them
under performing and let them go you
bear some responsibility right you made
a mistake in hiring them um so that's
part if you're not the person
responsible for hiring but you're stuck
with someone you're working with someone
who doesn't buy into the team goal um uh
that shouldn't impact your optimism
right it'll cause frustration but let's
be Crystal Clear what optimism is
optimism is not blind nor is it naive it
is not the same as blind or toxic
positivity everything's fine
everything's good everything's fine and
a lot of leaders make that mistake which
is in difficult times they falsely
believe they have to be positive and put
on a brave face every day to inspire the
team but it does the opposite because
when we're in the mud together and
you're blindly op uh blindly positive I
know we're in the mud so I just don't
believe you and so it actually makes
things worse or I look at you go oh my
God how can you be positive in this
difficult time there must be something
wrong with me so it backfires in a major
way right optimism is not the same
optimism is the undying belief that the
future is bright and you can stand in
dark
and you can Wade through difficulty in
mud and you can be honest about it we
are going through an incredibly
difficult time it is filled with
uncertainty and I am uncertain as well
but there's one thing I know for sure if
we work together through these difficult
times 100% guaranteed we will get
through this and we will come out of
this stronger than we went in even if I
don't know how long we're going to be in
the darkness that's optimism and no
matter who's on the team who uh may or
may not buy into the goal the goal is
not to obsess about the one or two
people who aren't bought in the goal is
to obsess about the cause the vision to
Rally the people who do believe and
hopefully that that that person who
doesn't buy in will either join or
extract themselves I'm very public about
people who don't buy into things I say
listen I don't mind that you don't
believe in this it actually doesn't
bother me right come to work do your job
do sort of the minimum that we need
punch your clock get your paycheck go
home I'm totally fine with that just
don't get in the way or sabotage what we
doing there's no cause for that there's
no reason for that right just do your
thing and we'll leave you alone but you
cannot
sabotage um uh and I think that's
totally okay to say um I've definitely
said it um not necessarily at somebody
that I've said it in in an audience you
know to a group of to a team like if you
don't believe in it I'm cool with it
just collect your paycheck and just
leave the rest of us alone there's no
reason you need to
sabotage nice um there's question from
Veron who I know has uh been working on
a startup and has pivoted a couple of
times so I think it might be coming from
that perspective his question is how do
you balance vision for the future and
also be able to take decisions in the
short
term so they're not mutually
exclusive um
um um of course you have to make
short-term decisions like of course um
but making sure you maintained vision
for the future includes things like
Integrity it includes things like
adherence to values right so you can
make short-term decisions but they have
to be consistent with with your values
they have to be consistant with a with a
high ethical standard um um of course
you can you can when you're trying to be
healthy you can eat chocolate cake just
don't eat too much of it like if you
need a short-term Sugar Rush if you need
a short-term infusion of something
you're going to do business with a
client who you know is a bad fit but you
need the cash fine do it but don't do it
under any illusions that this is the
future and everything's going to be
hunky dory or that that relationship's
going to be
enjoyable you know um the mistake is
when we keep making those decisions for
the short term then ultimately what will
break the organization the mistake we
make is you keep eating the chocolate
cake when you're trying to be healthy
and eventually it's the exercise just
isn't having the same impact as it used
to um uh so so short-term decisions are
fine but do them with eyes wide open
and and don't kid yourself or
rationalize things away you know I think
one of the biggest mistake young
entrepreneurs make is when they start to
seek investment and they take investment
from either the name brand investor or
they take investment from the person who
offers them the most money um but just
like uh remember there there most
investors uh are not looking to make a
long-term bet few are but not enough
they're looking for relatively
short-term bets and no matter what they
say at the beginning um way to few years
and you'll start to feel the pressure
for where the where those returns are
and the pressure to put lipstick on a
pig start to increase um and so the
number of times I hear from young
entrepreneurs the the big one of the
biggest struggles they have is actually
the pressure from their investors and I
always shrug my shoulders and say you
took the money and so um do your
homework you know go talk to some of
their other uh other companies that
they've invested in for example um find
out what it's like to work with them
find out if there's pressure find out
what how they treat you when things go
wrong find out what happens when you
want to make an ethically correct
decision but it might be financially uh
it might create a short-term liability
do they support you or do they Hammer
you to make the financially expedient
decision go go do your homework and then
have the guts to turn that investor down
to go with an in another investor who
may offer you less money um your
partners are your are you know are are
the most important thing you've got
especially an early stage um and so and
so you you you you know long-term Vision
means staying true to my values staying
true to the direction I'm going
open-minded to how I get there
open-minded to changing the product but
but remaining true to the the cause I'm
trying to advance that's that's how you
make shortterm decisions if you if you
close off your mind to what the future
looks like and to your values you're
things aren't going to go well or you
will be very uncomfortable as you go
down that
path yeah well speaking speaking of path
we've got a question here from Sam which
digs a little bit into your past here um
well training in cultural anthropology
was there one individual story or
Journey that really resonated with you
and how did their story impact your
thoughts and ideas what was that when
trending in cultural anthropology is
that what it was yeah well she said she
said ethnography but I think it was
cultural anthropology so yeah so so I
was a cultural anthom major that's true
and I did study uh ethnography um
um there's no one story that really uh
contributed but you know where a lot of
my colleagues were interested in sort of
you know some Amazonian tribe with you
know 15 members left you know those
kinds of cultures I was always
interested in Western Urban culture I
was interested in the culture in which I
live um and I did you know a bunch of I
did an independent study where I was in
student government I was the chairman of
the allocations board back in the day
and uh and so I I don't even know this
is public whoops but I basically did an
independent study simultaneously being
involved in student government where I
was actually writing papers about all
the leadership styles of the other
people I worked with in student
government they don't know that um and I
was learning about how
insecurity because I knew some of these
people were my friends right um how
insecurity impacts leadership style
sometimes insecurity makes us quiet and
demure and you know obsequious and
sometimes it makes us bombastic and over
compensate and I was fascinated by that
that it didn't come out in one flavor um
so that was pretty impactful to be
honest um where I started at a very
young age in college to recognize that
um how hard it is to tell someone's
motivation based on their leadership
style um you know uh uh and it really
made me fascinated and curious with how
organizations work when they
work well it's all public now now
um um to to great benefit of our
audience today all right well here's
here's a question from anoir um how
would you say we reconcile the humanity
of employees and of consumers in the age
of big data when essentially everything
is being reduced and understood as a
data
point um so you have to put a human face
back on on those data points right um
there's something called ethical fading
which is Insidious and ethical fading um
is when uh people make unethical
decisions believing they are still
within their own ethical framework in
other words they don't think they've
done anything wrong right and we see
this you know extreme examples are when
a pharmaceutical company will raise the
price of an essential drug for which
they have the patent 500% 800% 1,00%
1500% to meet some Financial
objective which is not illegal but
wholly unethical and we always drag them
in front of Congress and say why did you
do it they all say the same thing we
didn't do anything illegal no but my
goodness that was unethical right uh
what happened at Wells Fargo same thing
you know people started opening fake
bank accounts to help them meet their
short-term Financial objectives um in
some cases illegal but in many cases
wholly
unethical um and uh one of the things
that happens in ethical fading one of
the one of the criteria that that allows
ethical fading to happen is the overuse
of
euphemisms where we use language to
distance ourselves from the impact of
our decisions right so for example you
ask most CEOs would you ever spy on your
customers of course we would never spy
on our customers that's
insane data mining we love we love data
mining right now just call it what it is
it's spying on your customers right and
you'll find that if you actually call
things for what they are your ability to
navigate those ethical pitfalls actually
becomes a lot easier when we use
euphemisms to distance or disconnect
ourselves or to you know create this
sort of you know cozy uh view of things
like externalities we're managing
externalities you mean you're managing
the damage you're doing to the
environment and the Societies in which
you have your factories right just call
it what it is you know and then you'll
find managing exter externalities the
percentages that you found acceptable or
no longer acceptable my friend Bob
Chapman who runs a company called barri
way Miller doesn't even refer to head
count we have to reduce our head count
he refers to Heart count it's very
difficult to reduce a heart count right
and so language really matters when
you're navigating these things um and if
you call things for what they are um
you'll find your uh your find your
ability to make better
decisions uh go up um and so when the in
the CA in the case that you talk about
tech you have to put a a human face back
on numbers and there's been studies done
on this there's a there was um there was
a group of social scientists who did a
wonderful experiment where they took a
bunch of volunteers at a university who
were Dialing for Dollars for a
scholarship right during these Hard
Times we're looking for you to donate to
you know to whatever scholarship and the
numbers were kind of flat to down and so
they hired a consultant to rewrite the
script small but not very significant
impact and these social scientists
brought
in a recipient of the scholarship to
talk to the volunteers are you ready for
this for five minutes for five minutes
and talk about the impact the
scholarship had on their lives all of a
sudden they didn't have to obey a script
and they weren't doing it for some you
know uh ethereal mystical student
scholarship they were doing it for Stacy
over there I'm doing this I'm calling
you because I'm damn well going to get
more money for people like Stacy and it
became deeply
personal a division of of Wells Fargo in
St Louis the not the bad Wells Fargo is
like a little just a little Bank uh uh
uh same thing their small business loan
department there's just dealing with
numbers and creating you know everything
was a a spreadsheet and what they did
was is they brought in a recipient of
the small business loan to talk about
the impact that loan had on their life
and performance skyrocketed because
they're now doing it for a person so if
you find that you have dehumanized the
people you're supposed to be serving
bring in somebody who has benefited from
your product or your service to talk to
your employees and put a human face back
on it um letters work as well not as
effective the data shows as a human
being but it still has a positive impact
so you have to as a leader put human
faces not generic real people back to
those numbers humanize them rehumanize
them it also help you maintain higher
levels of Ethics as well that's one of
the reasons I think we have more
unethical Behavior a lot of unethical
behavior in companies is because they're
looking at spreadsheets and thinking
that those are
customers yeah um so this is another
question here about sort of people and
and teams um from IO you mentioned the
importance of building trust within
organizations and relationships for
college student students who are often
in short-term groups like a course
project what are some practical steps
that we could take to Foster trust and
collaboration among those types of teams
and in parenthesis I just put together
some teams that in this class will start
to work on a project so it's very it's
very timely yeah so um remember those
human skills we talked about listening
giving and receiving feedback you know
there that these are these are the
opportunities for those skills to
operate doesn't matter if this team is a
short-term team or a long-term team it
doesn't matter right a team is not a
group of people who work together a team
is a group of people who trust each
other and just because you were assigned
to work with somebody doesn't mean
you're a team yet you have to do the
hard work of building a team and
creating teaming um and uh whether a
leader is assigned or whether a leader
emerges um and it doesn't matter the
rank uh uh a leader recognized is that
they have a responsibility to see those
around them rise it's not about them and
their Glory it's not about I did all the
work you know um and what's fascinating
is a team
of average performers is outperform a
team of high performers every day um for
all of the reasons we're talking about
um which is are you in service to your
team or are you in service to yourself
um when I used to teach way back when um
I did team projects and the university
advised me
when because I made the teams I didn't
let them choose I would put my top
performers on one team I'd put my bottom
performers on another team and then I'd
spread out the average because my
original Instinct was to take my top
performers and put one of them on each
team right and the university said don't
do that and so I followed the
University's guidance and I put all my
top performers in one team and literally
as I announced the teams in the class
the rest of the class were like come on
like I'd stack the deck my top
performers never ever ever got the best
grade for their group projects never my
top performers spent more time in my
office going but I'm doing all the work
and that person's not doing the work and
is it going to affect my grade and what
happens about it my grade my grade me me
me me me the average performers because
they knew that they were middle of the
pack they worked together a hell of a
lot better and they always every year
outperform the top team every single
year because they were devoted to their
team rather than themselves they more
concerned about about each other's
grades in the group grade rather than my
grade and so that's part of teaming it's
showing up for the team and serve as
team not worrying about the disparities
of who's doing more or less work it
doesn't matter right um uh if somebody's
doing less work then brush them aside
like so what they're going to get your
grade I mean welcome to life you know um
yeah it's unfair um yeah yeah
congratulations yes it's unfair you did
all the work and they got a good grade
what do you care about them worry about
yourself right um and and so this is
this is what teaming is the hard work of
teaming is actually the hard work of
learning to build deep meaningful
relationships and I guarantee you if you
can learn the skills to be a better
listener a better team player at in your
group project you will find weird things
happening in your friendships and your
relationship with your parents and your
siblings and your girlfriends and your
boyfriends which is you'll notice that
those relationships are getting better
too because the skills are human skills
and they're transferable professionally
or
personally yeah um so so the next next
question again overlap here um it's
anonymous question how can you teach
others to tell apart projection from
objective reality on a team and then I
think this is a separate question is
emotional intelligence intelligence
teachable and so now yeah just how can
you teach others to tell aart projection
and objective reality because I think
some what you're saying was related to
that and then this other point is
emotional intelligence
teachable so how can you the first
question is a complicated one
because Define
reality right uh you
know belief is a powerful
thing and uh we are emotional animals we
are not rational animals we do not make
decisions rationally we are deeply
driven by fear and ambition and ego and
insecurity
that make our decisions for us um
uh often even people who think that
they're rational aren't rational you
know um and so when you talk about you
know convincing people to tell the
difference no it's this misunderstanding
how this stuff works your job isn't to
convince anybody of anything your job is
to understand where they're coming from
your job is to understand their world
viiew your job is to make them feel seen
and heard and understood your job is to
have
empathy not convince Inspire
invite uh those are words of
leadership um and sometimes if somebody
you have to allow people to go on their
own journey and if you have a different
view of the world that you think is a
good way for the world to be then learn
to invite people rather than exclude
people learn to listen to people you
know it's one of the biggest one of the
biggest coups of my own work I wasn't
the first person to talk about purpose
at work right but when I started talking
about it all those years ago talking
about purpose at work sounded like some
hippie dippy crap um and I didn't use
those words and I refused to word use
the words Vision or Mission because
there's no standardized definition of
what Vision or Mission are and everybody
had different definitions of what they
are and which one comes first and which
one is subordinate and so you end up
just having semantic debates which is
pointless and so the the coup was that I
changed the language I called it the why
right because I talked to people who
believe Vision came first and I said
well what's Vision they said well it's
why we get out of bed every day and I
talked to people who believe Mission
comes first I said well what's Mission
they said well it's why we do what we do
I talked to people who believed brand
came first or purpose came first or
whatever language for the same thing and
they all had the same definition I said
great we'll call it the why now we can
all agree and the coup was I found
language that invited people you know
rather than me standing trying to
convince
people um um uh and so I think that's
that's a huge part of it um which is if
you're if you're setting out to convince
anybody of anything um if they have a
strongly held belief you've
lost you've lost before you've started
it's like convince somebody who believes
in God that God doesn't exist good luck
with
that right why not try and understand
where their faith comes from and how it
drives them and how what what value it
has in their lives and the importance
and you don't have to agree with them
but you can understand them and you can
learn to speak to them in their terms
and you can learn to find common ground
that you know though you not may not
believe the same thing as them you also
have belief and faith in certain things
and you'll find that you actually have
more in common than you don't that's
called an
invitation but
convincing uh do you want to be
convinced do you want someone to
convince you that you're wrong with your
deep deep held beliefs no you're going
to get pretty damn defensive so it's the
same when we do it the other way around
great and then so the the second
question on that question actually I'm
going to I'm G to add another question
to the second question which is is
emotional intelligence teachable and
there's another question here I like
it's uh so um I struggle with
uncomfortable conversations do you have
any book recommendation for having
uncomfortable conversations so I feel
part of this is a question about
learning like you we talking about these
things teachable skills well we're in
school we have books how you know which
books should we go to or yeah so the the
first question about emotional
intelligence is it teachable of course
it's
teachable uh can someone learn to be a
parent of
course right we you know when you're
single I mean you only care about
yourself and when you're a young couple
you you only care about us and then you
have a new life in the world and you
have to learn to put your own interests
aside for the interest of another of
another human being you have to learn
empathy you have to learn listening you
have to learn to affirm feelings those
are all that's all emotional
intelligence and you learned it because
you're trying not to screw this kid up
right um and uh so yes of course it's
learnable if you want to learn it um
it's not necessarily easy and it takes a
lot of practice like Le skill you can't
just like read a book and then ride a
bicycle it's like you're gonna you're
gonna have to practice this stuff in
real life um and same goes with the
books which is you know I I have a
couple of books that I think are great
go-to books for learning communication
one of them is how to uh how to listen
to kids so kids will listen how to talk
to kids so kids will listen and listen
so kids will talk yes it's a parenting
book and I think it's one of the best
books on how to how to talk and how to
have these conversations and how to
understand emotions and it covers all
these subjects and I think you should
read it for business um because it's
great um um because it's all
transferable skills it's people talking
to people and turns out we're just like
like little kids um but the the real the
real heavy lifting is not the reading
and passing a test the real heavy
lifting is doing it and if I can just
take a little aside and go on a little
rant on a little Soap Box um you know
what it means to listen like how do you
know you're a good listener like how do
you know when you're practicing
listening and all of these you know uh
emotional intelligence that you're
supposedly learning how do you know it's
working and the example I'll give is the
concept of meditation if anyone has ever
meditated you know the problem with what
we've done in the west is we've made
meditation a selfish Pursuit right I
need to be more grounded I need to be
more present I need to focus the day so
I'm I've got my meditation practice for
me you know get out of the my mat you're
sitting on my meditation mat I'm like I
think you're missing the point you know
but the value of meditation though there
is huge value to the self absolutely the
true value of meditation is that it's a
service given to others it's a practice
right so think about it if you've ever
meditated one of the things you do when
you meditate is you learn to focus on
one thing you can't clear your mind
that's nonsense when they say clear your
mind that that doesn't exist but you do
learn to focus on one thing whether it's
your Mantra or a sound or a DOT on the
wall or your breath it doesn't matter
you're focusing on one thing and when
you get distracted you learn to bring
yourself back to that one thing and when
you have a thought you learn to label it
a thought put out of your mind and say
I'll deal with that later and you go
back to focusing on one thing and the
amazing thing is is you feel really
present and grounded at the end of it
but that skill that you're learning is
for the benefit of others you are not
present until someone else says you are
so when you're having a conversation
with a friend who's telling you about
their good day or their bad day their
relationship struggles or their
stroubles troubles with their roommate
whatever it is because you've been
practicing meditation you've learned to
focus on one thing and one thing only
what they're telling you and when you
hear a a noise on the side you ignore it
you've learned to put that aside and
when you have a thought you don't feel
compelled to say it or wait for your
turn to speak you learn to put that
thought out of your mind and say I'll
get to it later right now I'm focused on
one thing and one thing only at the end
of that conversation your friend will
say to you thank you for listening I
feel so heard thank you for being
present congratulations all that work
that you did with your meditation
practice is now bearing fruit for this
one day that you made someone else feel
seen and heard and understood and that
is really the goal of all of this stuff
that we're talking about whether it's
empathy or emotional intelligence the
benefit is always for others that's what
it is um and so yes you learn them but
you have to practice them and you don't
know that it's working until somebody
else has told you this is
working great way to think about
meditation um okay well as expected
there's there's there's a bunch there's
a number of brandise questions in here
so I'm I'm just gonna bring it down to
two um the first brandise question is
did your time at brandise help you learn
to have these conversations and the
second one is what were some clarifying
moments during your brandise days as a
student that have helped to shape your
career Andor personal aspirations and
accomplishments so one of the so
remember I went to Brand in a time where
the internet was just starting so we
didn't have social media and we didn't
have cell phones so slightly different
context as well about how the value of
emotional intelligence how it works
right because I think it's more
complicated now for sure and I think
that the Youth of today have more
disadvantages in in in you know like
when you're feeling a little bit lonely
you can Retreat to social media you know
and you can avoid having to have
difficult conversations you can turn on
your Tik Tok and cry to your cell phone
in your room by yourself and you can get
lots of likes and external affirmation
but that that's not vulnerability go
have that exact same conversation and
cry to the the friend that hurt you
that's way more difficult and I think we
avoid those conversations because it's
just easier and I think unbalance not
exclusively but unbalance we see a
younger generation that's very afraid of
being uncomfort com fortable they like
to avoid discomfort unbalance and so one
of the things that I learned at Brand
dice was being uncomfortable you know
I've got a roommate for the first time I
had a roommate who I signed up to live
with a non-smoker okay my roommate
signed up to be with a non-smoker turns
out my roommate was a smoker who didn't
want to live with a
smoker you're an right so now I
got to live with a smoker right I had to
learn to live with that I had to learn
to live with a room that used to screw
with my stuff because he thought it was
cool with his friends and so like he
would just I he'd like just screw with
my stuff and so I learned to not believe
in
Revenge right I learned not to believe
in Revenge and the reason is simple is
because when we did have a fight I could
say you did this and this and this and
this and he couldn't say anything
because I don't believe in Revenge I
didn't do anything
back right I learned that skill because
of my my my useless roommate my freshman
Europe
at brandise I had to learn it it was a
survival mechanism otherwise I'm going
to be screaming and yelling all the time
right and I'm going to two wrs don't
make it wrong I had to learn that too
right but one of the best lessons I
learned at Brand I and one of the great
things about brand I as a relatively
small school you have relatively small
class sizes and more importantly you
have very very small student to teacher
ratios you know our classes are taught
by professors you go to Harvard they're
going to be taught by Tas because all of
the good professors go work with The
Graduate students right so you get
access to brilliant brilliant people in
small class sizes this is amazing this
is a gift and one of the things that I
learned was that I have I am allowed to
disagree with someone who has more
degrees and more letters at the end of
their name than I do as long as I can
make a constructive and respectful
argument screaming and yelling is not
the way I disagree telling somebody that
they're wrong is not the way I disagree
but mounting an argument in a respectful
way is something I learned at at
brandise so I would have the emotion to
disagree but I had to learn how to
disagree in a constructive way very
grateful to brandise for giving me that
and that I could do it in these small
class sizes where I could talk directly
to the
authority um so super grateful for a lot
of the human skills that I learned at
brandise and I think one of the great
things that we learn in college whether
you know you know there's a lot of
debate whether college is useless or not
in this modern day and age and yes I
mean the studying part may or may not be
useful um but the it's a halfway house
to the real world you know um and I
think that you're learning to transition
to adulthood you're learning to trans
transition to Independence um and most
importantly um you learn to think
critically um you know where College is
very different than high school and the
way professors talk to you and the way
you can talk to your professors is very
different than high school and critical
thinking is the thing you need to do and
you're talking to professors who don't
necessarily know the answers themselves
in high school they know all the answers
right and so you're about it's about
problem solving and that's really hard
when sometimes there is no right
answer um that's even harder you're
doing work in in your category where
sometimes there actually is no answer
and so what you're teaching is how to
think not what the answer is and that
skill how to think rather than know the
answer for the test is more valuable in
my life than pretty much anything I've
ever
learned yeah thank you
all right this um this could be a tricky
question so this is from Izzy you've
been on many podcasts and have had uh
many thought leaders on your podcast
who's been your favorite speaker to talk
to or someone who has totally changed
your mind about
something um I mean I don't I I don't
think there's a favorite I don't think
that's you know there are some that
stand out that you know they've
challenged a point of view that I have
or have given me a new way to think
about something person I talked to
recently was about um uh uh uh turning
turning uh anxiety into something
positive right that anxiety is not
necessarily a bad thing and we had a
whole conversation about that and the
thing that I took away from that that I
absolutely love um is uh um is that we
talk about mental health all the time
and the problem with the term mental
health is it's we treat it like it's a
goal that if you're anything other than
perfect there's something wrong with you
right which of course is nonsense right
that if if you're anything other than
happy all the time then then you're then
you're struggling with your mental
health well we know when we when we when
we do physical fitness sometimes your
muscles hurts sometimes you have a good
workout sometimes you have a bad workout
sometimes you're strong sometimes you're
weak sometimes you got a ton of sleep
and you can't work out sometimes you got
no sleep and you're like on fire you
have the best run of your life and we
don't call we there's no goal it's
Fitness like it's something you're
constantly working and I think I stopped
calling it mental health and I started
calling it mental Fitness and so having
emotions having a down day being
depressed you know be feeling lonely
like all of these things are fine and
they're totally healthy if you get stuck
in any one of them that's a problem but
by the way if you get stuck in happiness
that's a problem too you know and and so
I think we have to work on our mental
Fitness um which is learning how to have
feelings learning how to just in be in
our
feelings um because I think we've set up
an unrealistic expectation for ourselves
that if you have a negative feeling
there's something wrong with you and if
you have a negative feeling turns out
you're human um and I think the biggest
skill that's lacking uh in all of that
is uh learning how to ask for help um
that when we do have negative feelings
where the first thing we should be do is
reaching out to a friend we don't and I
have a rule with my friends and all my
friends know this which is no crying
Alone um and I've had some people who
are well-known entrepreneurs who you
know many of your class will know and
we've had experiences where the phone
rings and they say can I talk to you go
of course what's on what's going on and
they start crying because that's the
rule no crying alone and we lean on each
other very very heavily because none of
us is stupid enough to believe we can do
this thing called life or
entrepreneurship or career by ourselves
just not that good not that strong um
and so um talking talking about anx
xiety that that episode really helped
frame some of the stuff that uh that I
work
through yeah um thank you so here's
question about tying some of these
things in very much to what's going on
in in society at large so question is
when starting the curve how did you
persuade the police and sheriffs to
share their opinions and cooperate to
improve the policing culture and
statistically in your opinion how has
the curve changed the profession of
policing in
America so uh thanks for bringing that
up so the curve is a is a charity that I
founded um that is devoted to uh
modernizing policing today and evolving
their cultures from the inside out you
know there's a lot of pressure on the
outside to change policing but there
needs to be more pressure there needs to
be more work from changing policing um
from the inside of the organizations so
I going back to all the conversation
we've already had I didn't convince
anybody of anything I talked about what
I
believed I talked about what I stood for
and Chiefs and sheriffs came to me and
said hey we've been using leaders e last
to help completely change our policing
organization based on your work thank
you and I said I'd like to learn more
and so my work served as an invitation
my work served as a
lighthouse my public words and how I
believe organization should operate
attracted the right kinds
of police Chiefs and sheriffs and so the
the the all of the founding members of
the curve are Chiefs and sheriffs from
across the country Republicans and
Democrats from across the whole country
who we share a common value set even
though we may see the world differently
and we all are devoted to teaching the
skills of leadership inside policing
which are desperately desperately
lacking leadership inside the policing
profession is about 20 years behind uh
that's how bad it is
and so that's where we're starting we're
starting with some of the basics like
what is a leader and promoting people
because they're good leaders not because
they passed a test um It's The more I've
learned about it it is an unbelievably
complicated problem you know there's
18,000 police forces in the United
States of which the vast majority are
fewer than 75 cops so most of them are
pretty small agencies and there's no
National Police Chief there's no like
one person be like we're going to change
policing like this it doesn't exist
there's no National stand standards
there's no naal standards for training I
mean it's it's it's a mad house um and
so and so where the reason we're called
The Curve is because we're leveraging
the law of diffusion we're looking for
all those early adopter Chiefs and
sheriffs to create a critical mass that
we can change the whole profession um
and so when you're ask when the question
ask is what impact have we made the cool
thing is we're gaining momentum and more
and more Chiefs and sheriffs are
reaching out to us saying I want to do
something different this isn't working I
don't know where to start can you help
and the fact that they're open-minded to
something different and new is hugely
inspiring but the but the challenge is
is
astronomical in in its scope comp and
complexity um so I think this is our
final question so the previous question
if somebody wants to learn more about
the curve check out the curve. Org the
curve. org and you can read about my
philosophies on policing and what needs
to be done um and any support you want
to give you want a villain teer and help
out I'll take it awesome um so this
question I feel flips it not takes it
out of policing but flips it you know
the curb the sheriffs the the leaders
the Chiefs um is what you just talked
about the question here is as a young
person in the Working World I'm
frustrated by how often the ego of
leaders gets in the way of positive
change within organizations How Can
employees influence leaders who may not
see the issues with their decisions but
are Al not open to
feedback um okay you're not going to
like my
answer and you'll notice a consistency
in all of my answers you cannot change
their point of view right no number of
anonymously sent books will change their
mind right though I encourage you to
keep trying um uh you know no Angry
conversations or meetings will change
it's just not going to happen all right
and so you're you're barking up the
wrong tree right it's not about how do I
change my leader it's how do I be the
leader I wish I had leadership has
nothing to do with rank rank affords you
Authority that's it but it doesn't make
you a leader right leadership is the
ultim responsibility to see those around
us rise and if you have rank if you have
authority you can just lead at scale and
so what you want to do is be the leader
you wish you had and you not going to
change somebody two three four levels up
who disagrees and doesn't who ignores
all of the stuff that I'm talking about
right like we've lost them right or
they'll come they'll have their come to
Jesus Mo a different way right which
sometimes
happens but if you lead if you are the
leader you wish you had and this is why
I want to see young people if they go
through discomfort or they have a leader
who's they don't buy into please don't
quit right please stay there and
practice the difficult magical wonderful
honorable skill of leadership with your
team even if you're the most Junior
person you have somebody to the left of
you and you have somebody to the right
of you and you can commit to seeing that
they feel seen heard and understood you
can commit to helping them achieve their
goals you can commit to making them feel
like someone has their back in difficult
times you can commit to helping them um
and you can commit to helping ensure
that when they go home at the end of the
day that they feel fulfilled and they
had a good day at work that's called
leadership and what you'll start to find
is if you can do that if you can develop
that skill set that these little teams
start to be higher performing they start
to get along better the teaming starts
to happen really well and Leadership
will either ignore you because you're
doing fine or you they may surprise you
and be like what are they doing down
there I'm really curious they may
actually come and learn from you and
eventually one of you is going to get
promoted out of that group and go to
another team and they're going to take
all the skills they learn from you and
they're going to bring them to their new
team and now you're going to have two
high performing wonderful teams that are
highly trusting and and and magical and
then three and then five and then 10 and
before you know it the tail wags the dog
and this is the one of the hardest
things I think young people struggle
with which is which is we're talking
about a long-term mindset we're talking
about an infinite mindset here which is
the speed at which it takes for the tail
to rag the dog is unpredictable the
reason a lot of businesses ignore all of
my work is not because it's wrong or
they disagree it's because they want it
to work on the day they want it to work
which is the exact same thing is saying
to me Simon I'm exercising and I need to
be healthy on this exact day on this
exact time I'm like I mean maybe it'll
work out that way you know it's like
every doctor will tell you if you work
out 20 minutes a day for the rest of
your life you're going to be super
healthy right but on what day on what
day you're healthy on what day your
blood you know your blood pressure gets
better nobody knows sometimes quick
sometimes slow I don't know but you have
to commit to the process and 100% of the
time the process works I just don't know
when and Leadership is the same 100% it
works I just don't know when and people
come quickly and people come slowly so
you may convert an entire organization
in a year or you may just simply build
the momentum that it'll continue without
you but you won't get to see it change
that's possible too um so but the most
important thing is to commit to the
regime like brushing your teeth you know
brushing your teeth every day brushing
your teeth does nothing unless you do it
all the time every day can I take a
night off yes I you can it won't do any
damage how many nights can I take off I
don't know and neither does any dentist
just not too many right same thing
commit to the regime be the leader you
wish you had don't worry about
convincing other
people perfect um thank you so much um I
did also just want to mention I think I
should have said this at the outset but
I did also want to thank the
international business school hay career
center and Brandy Alumni Association for
bringing us all together today to um
share this experience and opportunity to
listen to Simon syn Simon thank you so
much it's been great really appreciate
your perspective on on all these
questions and um yeah I I don't I don't
know if the students can say thank you I
think actually as participants we can't
hear them we can't we can't listen but
um I know that everyone uh thanks you so
well some of them
anyway exactly um uh you're very thanks
for having me it's nice to be back uh uh
at brandise hopefully soon uh in person
um and until then take care of yourself
and take care of each other thanks very
much for having me great thank you so
much bye everyone